I feel like you could be able to see it
in my face and I love what I'm doing
right now it's enjoying my life Selena
Gomez still all about enjoying life the
source tells ET she's happy embracing
being single and is 100% focused on
herself quote she's not interested in
dating anyone she still doesn't feel
ready I don't know I come I'm at that
age where I feel like that's what
matters is making sure I'm healthy and
people are happy that I love but our
source says the 26 year old would love
to be in a new relationship eventually
and her friends are hoping to play
matchmaker quote when the time is right
and for the right guy she's totally open
to trusting her friends with setting her
up and get this her pals want to find
her someone who's talented and
successful but not a celebrity
oh no I go back to the source size cells
friends want her to be with someone
worthy and that they weren't big fans of
Justin Bieber but still Selena remains
happy for her ex's engagement to Haley
Baldwin quote she wants nothing but
happiness for them
[Music]
[Applause]